[Musique]
on peut être mère d'une petite commune
rurale sans être originaire de cette
commune ou même de ses environs c'est le
cas de Joceline mollet imaginez elle est
née à Casablanca elle a vécu en Côte
d'Ivoire dans le Midi et à Lyon et elle
est venue s'installer ici à La Guiche en
son etloire une commune de 750 habitants
dont elle est devenue maire en juillet
2020 c'est son premier mandat et je vous
propose d'aller la
rencontrer
[Musique]
bonjour madame le Maire bonjour merci de
nous accueillir bienvenue à La Guiche
alors on est on est où exactement ici
vous êtes dans la salle du conseil de
donc de la commune on peut s'installer
allez-y
installez-vous alors madame Mollé je
vous propose de revenir en arrière et
aux origines de votre vocation j'ai
consulté votre discours d'investit s
lors de votre élection le 4 juillet 2020
voilà vos mots je tiens à remercier les
guichois et les guichoises qui m'ont élu
bien que je sois néo habitante de la
commune je ne suis pas né à La Guiche ni
même aux environs mais j'ai choisi de
vivre dans ce village est-ce que vous
pouvez m'expliquer un petit peu votre
parcours et votre arrivée donc à la
Guiche j'étais euh d'abord dans le Midi
j'habitais à hier dans le midi pour des
raisons professionnelles je suis arrivé
à Lyon on cherchait une résidence
secondaire et en visitant Cluni on a eu
l'occasion de passer devant une agence
immobilière voir une maison qui nous
plaisait et on est arrivé à La Guiche
alors qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé du
coup à passer le pas et à entrer en
politique pas vraiment en politique
parce qu'on est quand même dans une
petite commune et je je tiens justement
à ce qu'il n'y ait pas trop de politique
et lorsque effectivement les élections
sont arrivées en 2000 en
2020 l'équipe municipale que en poste
pas demander si je voulais
participer pourquoi pas mais rien ne me
prédestinait au poste de mère j'avais
dit éventuellement conseiller pourquoi
pas mais mais bon les choses se sont
faites comme ça donc vous avez été élu
maire de La Guiche sans avoir jamais
fait de mandat même avant en tant que
conseillère municipale jamais jamais
c'était une peur ça de se lancer comme
ça sans finalement
d'expérience une peur non pas vraiment
une peur mais bon une quelques
interrogations quand même parce que je
ne savais pas où où j'allais ce que je
voulais c'était effectivement on a tout
de suite aimer ce village donc en fait
ce que l'envie c'était ça c'était de
promouvoir le La Guiche
de pas de l'améliorer mais d'amener de
la nouveauté du S9 aussi parce que bon
venant d'ailleurs on avais peut-être
enfin j'avais peut-être d'autres
d'autres
idées
alors madame Mollé je reprends à nouveau
votre discours d'investiture où vous
disiez nous pouvons lutter contre cette
désertification nous pouvons sortir la
Guiche de son isolement c'est ça l'une
de vos priorités relancer l'attractivité
ici complètement complètement ce que ce
que je souhaite effectivement c'est
valoriser redonner à la Guiche je dirais
ces lettres de noblesse l'année dernière
on s'est lancé on a fait un appel à
projet qui a été accepté donc on a
commencer les travaux de ce terrain de
tennis on peut aller voirz voilà bien
sûr l'idée c'était de faire un lieu
sportif et convivial donc on a continué
donc avec les jeux pour enfants on a
fait installer une table de ping-pong
fixe et puis après on s'est dit et les
et les grands les adultes on va bien
leur faire quelque chose donc on a fait
installer donc ce que vous voyez le
parcours d'agré pour adultes l'idée à
travers des investissements comme ceci
c'est de d'attirer des familles ici à La
Guiche et d'amener de nouveaux habitants
tout à fait c'est toujours pareil à
partir du moment où on donne quelque
chose les gens en profitent si on ne
propose rien effectivement il y aura
jamais rien cet enjeu de votre mandat
ramener des familles ici relancer
l'attractivité de de la Guiche est-ce
que c'est aussi finalement en lien avec
votre histoire personnelle qui est que
vous n'êtes pas de la Guiche et que vous
êtes venu vous y installer tout à fait
tout à fait tout à fait j'ai j'ai envie
de rire dans la dans la vie de ce de ce
village je dis toujours parce qu' on m'a
on m'avait fait quelquefis la réflexion
de me dire mais de toute façon vous
n'êtes pas d'ici alors je fais une
réponse toute simple je dis
effectivement je ne suis pas d'ici je
n'ai aucune attache à La Guiche je
n'avais aucune attache à La Guiche mais
la différence c'est que moi j'ai choisi
de venir à La
[Musique]
Guiche
on arrive dans l'école
maternelle on nous a annoncé en début
d'année donc en janvier 2023 que l'école
maternelle devait devait fermer on a
réussi à négocier une année
supplémentaire on s'est engagé à faire
un regroupement pédagogique avec la
commune voisine donc le le c'est marisie
d'accord la proposition que la Guiche a
faite c'était de garder la maternelle
ici parce qu'on a trouvé qu'elle était
mieux adapté elle est de plein pied elle
est au cœur du village la cantine est
toute proche sauf que bon ben
apparemment le conseil municipal de de
marisie a voté contre cette proposition
eux souhaitent donc conserver la
maternelle de leur côté à marisie
comprennent au niveau de la Guiche les
CP CE 1 CE2 et les CM1 CM2 repartirai à
marisie un enjeu comme ça c'est central
pour pour un maire local m en ruralité
c'est une problématique essentielle
effectivement c'est une c'est une des
plus grosses problématique de je dirais
du mandat actuel vous vous voyez
continuer c'est quoi votre avenir 2026
vous y pensez déjà j'imagine que votre
question c'est surtout est-ce que vous
continuez ou pas est-ce que vous
continuez ou pas
je pense que je me représenterai oui je
pense parce que je me pour moi il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire il y a
encore des projets qui sont qui sont en
cours donc j'ai envie de voir leur
réalisation donc si je peux oui je me
représenterai merci Madame le Maire
merci à vous en tout cas très heureuse
de vous avoir reçu dans notre petite
[Musique]
commune